thank you so I'm supposed to talking to
two microphones at the same time this is
gonna be interesting but yeah thanks for
coming to my talk my name is Tim Switzer
and I'm a data scientist at stitch fix
in San Francisco and I'll be talking
about mixed effects models in Python so
I'll give you a little bit of context
and motivation tell you about stitch fix
and the sorts of problems that I work on
there I will go over what mixed effects
models are and how they can be used for
some generic recommender system kind of
problems I will go into the computation
computational considerations of these
models and then at the end I will talk
about diamond which is a Python package
that I wrote with my colleagues at
stitch fix for fitting these kinds of
models so Citrix is an e-commerce
company and bear with me here David
there we go Citrix is an e-commerce
company customers come to our website
they give some information about their
style preferences and all they are and
their size and we take the information
they give us we combine it with
information that we have about our
merchandise the clothes that we have in
inventory such as the color of the
garments and the material we combine
these and do some machine learning and
then we make suggestions which are
consumed by human stylists so the
stylist look at our recommendations they
pick out five things they get mailed off
to the customer and customers keep what
they like and sent back everything else
so the part that I work on is uh what I
am calling algorithmic recommendations
here so for the purposes of this talk
it's a pretty standard recommender
system kind of application where we have
users who see certain items and provide
some kind of explicit feedback on those
items
so let's get into a little bit of math
so the straw poll I conducted a few
minutes ago most of you identified as
data scientists so I'm assuming that you
are familiar with the linear model so I
will just give you a brief refresher
suppose that you have gone out into the
world and observed some data and one of
the things you have observed is special
you're you have this variable Y that you
wish to explain in terms of some X's so
a very simple place to start is with a
linear model and you posit that your Y
variable is just a linear combination of
your X variables and there's some noise
in the system and what you want to do is
find this this vector of coefficients
beta okay
everybody I'm sure everyone in this room
has fit a linear model before so mixed
effects model builds on this by adding a
second set of coefficients and a second
design matrix so before we had X and
beta which we still have and now we have
another matrix and vector of
coefficients Z and B and Z can have some
of the same columns as X or different
columns in general you can put whatever
you want in there but where as the betas
are unknown but constants the B
coefficient vector is considered to be
drawn from a normal distribution
centered at zero with some some unknown
covariance matrix Sigma ok so that's the
the basic math of a mixed effects model
let me give you an illustration of why
such a model might be useful so I work
on clothing primarily women's clothing
and let's suppose that you that you want
to learn some relationship between the
ideal length of women's jeans and how
tall the woman is so you start with a
linear model and say that I think
the right length for the jeans is going
to be some intercept plus something
proportional to height so taller women
should have longer jeans and then
there's some some intercept that you
start with but this is not quite not
enough because you also think that the
jeans might need to be longer or shorter
depending on the silhouette so if
they're skinny jeans or wide leg jeans
or straight leg jeans the the jeans
might need to be longer or shorter for a
woman of the same height and the reason
this might be the case is this reason so
the model on the left is wearing skinny
jeans and you can see that they end at
about her ankle whereas the model on the
right is wearing bootcut jeans with
heels and these extend down below her
ankle halfway down her foot so if these
models were the same height the skinny
jeans would clearly need to be shorter
than the bootcut jeans so let's think
about how we went how we might fit the
simple linear model the one that ignores
silhouette so we're gonna model length
as our X matrix times our unknown
coefficients beta and a row of our X
matrix is going to be we're gonna have
an intercept so that's the first column
of X and then the second column of X is
going to be the woman's height so this
row that I drew randomly this woman is
is five foot four inches tall and we can
fit this model if we have some data on
how tall women are and how long are the
jeans that fit them well and we could
use something like stats models to you
know to fit this model to our data and
steth models uses formula notation or
people familiar with formula notation so
nod some nose
formula notation so I guess this is the
on the bottom of this slide I have the
mathematical notation formal imitation
just says this is my response variable
and I want to fit an intercept plus
height as a linear term and I want to
fit this model using this data so people
who have an R background are very
familiar with what formula notation but
it's used in some Python packages such
as stats models and the package that we
wrote called Dimond also uses formula
notation and if you fit this model what
you get is this nice straight line with
the intercept and slope parameters that
you learned
okay so then mixed effects you can also
fit this with stats models and we start
with the same part the same the initial
formula is the same we're going to
explain length with an intercept plus
some slope on height using the same
training data and then we're going to
fit an intercept for each silhouette and
then we take that and run and what that
gives us is this set of parallel lines
so I have kept the the overall average
in black here and what we have done is
allow the different silhouettes to have
different intercepts so we can see that
indeed bootcut jeans need to be a bit a
bit longer whereas skinny jeans are a
bit shorter and then a straight leg and
wide leg jeans are somewhere in the
middle so we have learned that indeed
there are some differences in ideal
length by silhouette so how did we learn
this let's go back to the math I said
before that our model in mixed effects
it has to design matrices with different
coefficients so our X matrix as before
is just a column column of one for the
intercept
and height and our Z matrix because
we're only interested in fitting a an
intercept for each silhouette our Z
matrix is going to be just all ones and
zeros but strategically placed so
imagine taking our data and sorting it
all by silhouette so that all of the
pairings of women and her height and the
length of the jeans all of those
observations for bootcut jeans are at
the top followed by the observations for
skinny jeans and straight leg jeans and
wide leg jeans and then we basically
repeat the first column or X matrix in
other words that column of ones for the
intercept we repeat that in Z only for
those observations that it is relevant
for so in other words for the the
bootcut observations we have we have a
column of ones and then zeros everywhere
else
likewise for skinny likewise for
straight and wide leg jeans and this
gives us our original X design matrix
was n by 2 and now because we have we're
fitting one parameter and we have free
silhouette and we have four silhouettes
now we have an N by four design matrix Z
and we'll learn different intercepts for
each of these so yeah and the cute the
key assumption here is that each of
these intercepts is drawn from some
normal distribution centered at zero and
the amazing thing about mixed effects
models is that it learns this this
variance parameter so what if in
practice what this means is that groups
that are small will get pulled towards
this uh this normal this normal sort of
like a you're familiar with Bayesian
statistics this is sort of a normal
prior and what this will do is for small
groups it will pull them towards towards
the mean or towards zero
so if we have if one of our groups is
much smaller than the other ones
in this example wide leg jeans are not
very common so we don't have very many
observations for them so even though
they might have a very different
relationship between length and height
this regularization will pull them too
towards the mean and not let them stray
too far and this the way this happens is
because we're including an intercept for
an overall intercept and then we're
regularizing deviations from that
overall meet okay so that's an example
using a simple example of through how
mix defects models work with a little
bit of formula notation and math let me
give you another example of mixed
effects models for a more generic kind
of recommender system so again these are
this is a scenario where you have users
and items users see some items and
provide some kind of rating of those
items so a very very basic model you
might you might start with for a
recommender systems problem is it just
fits some kind of global mean and then
you have a bias term for every user and
a bias term for every item and you
assume that the bias terms for users are
drawn from some normal distribution with
some variance and likewise for items and
this will let you learn stuff which is
learn things which are very common in
recommender system problems which is
that some users are more picky than
others and some items are much more
popular than other items but because
mixed effects models are built on top of
linear models it's easy to throw
features in so you could add in some
item features to the user group and if
for a clothing application this this
could be features like
color and material and that would allow
us to learn like individual users
preferences for different
characteristics of the items or we could
put user features such as age into the
item group and now it allow us to learn
whether certain items are more popular
with younger or older clients again we
assume that our coefficients are drawn
from now multivariate normal
distributions centered at zero using
features is great it allows us to learn
the Preferences I just mentioned it also
helps with the cold start problem for
new items and new users unfortunately if
we have three features in here an
intercept and then to item features we
have to learn a three by three
covariance matrix and in general if we
had P features we would need to learn P
by P covariance matrix which scales as P
squared so that is not so good I want to
make a comment about this model which is
that we have extent made we have come a
long way from the simple linear model so
now we have lots of features and we're
learning a lot more but this is still a
parametric model and much less flexible
than other kinds of models like neural
networks or matrix factorization or tree
ensembles but I don't want you to to
think that I'm claiming that mixed
effects models are better than any of
these I'm not claiming that in any way
you can use mixed effects models in
combination with all of these other
things and fit them all and then
ensemble them or use boosting or however
you like to combine models I think that
mixed effects models deserve to be one
of the one of the tools in the data
scientist toolkit
okay let's address the computation of
these models a Citrix for a long time we
were using R and we're using the L me
for package which is based on maximum
likelihood which is the traditional
statistical estimation procedure and for
these models the computation goes like
this we start with some estimate of the
covariance matrix Sigma given that we
can compute estimates for beta and B all
of our coefficients and with all of this
we can compute the log likelihood and
then we can go back and adjust our
estimate of Sigma to increase the log
likelihood and we just loop through
these until until the whole thing
converges unfortunately this does not
scale well with a number of observations
I don't know what the Big O performance
is off the top of my head but I have
some empirical results that will
convince you that this is true in a
couple of slides only four is nice
because it supports a variety of
generalized linear models so you can use
it to do not just linear regression but
logistic regression or Poisson
regression or a bunch of other flavors
but its generality means that it's not
optimized for any of any of those in
particular the other thing is that a lot
of our production models that stitch fix
we think it's important to refit these
models frequently because we think that
the parameters are non stationary in
other words they change over time
but we're willing to assume or we think
that our hyper parameters are more
stationary the or at least that they
change more slowly so if we're refitting
models every day it seems unnecessary to
refit the hyper parameters every day it
seems like it would be adequate to fix
the hyper parameters wreath freeze them
for a while updating updating the
coefficients beta and B and then once in
a while update the hyper parameters
so to that end we wrote this package
Dimond so it does not solve does not do
all the things that Ella me for does in
particular it does not learn this this
hyper parameter covariance matrix Sigma
you have to input Sigma but the nice
thing is that conditional on that the
optimization problem of finding the
coefficients is convex which means we
can use some tricks from convex
optimization so some of the tricks we
use are the Hessian of the penalized log
likelihood function and this involves in
pencil and paper math so we only did it
for the models that we use a lot in
particular logistic regression and
cumulative logistic regression which is
a nice model if you have ordinal
response data this is not a very popular
model so I have rope I have Illustrated
what that model form is here and the
other thing we do in diamond is we use
some quasi Newton optimization
techniques from a paper by Thomas minka
okay but diamond is not the only way to
fit models like this I gave some
examples before using stats models but
mixed effects models have a very
Bayesian sort of flavor and so that's
another approach to fitting these kind
of models so maybe I convinced you that
mixed effects models are worth
considering and you want to try fitting
them here are a few ways that you might
go about doing that if you if you want
to embrace the fully Bayes paradigm you
can do Markov chain Monte Carlo sampling
which is a perfectly good approach and
there are a number of good Python
packages for doing this you can use
Dimond if you are willing to specify
your hyper parameter somehow staff
models will fit some simple mixed
effects models but only for linear
regression and only for one grouping
factor or if you're willing to use R you
can use Allen before
but this can be awkward if you're you
know if your production pipeline is
Python Python Python Python Python
Python it's awkward displays are in the
middle so and these are sort of I call
these exact methods I mean they're all
they're all really approximations
because there's no analytic solution but
these are attempting to solve really the
problem that you want there's another
class of methods that solve a problem
that is hopefully close to your original
problem so for example in the full Bayes
paradigm variational inference allows
you to write down a fully Bayesian model
and it doesn't fit that exactly but
tries to find a solution which is close
to that in some sense likewise there are
some moment based methods for fitting
mixed effects models that come up with
an approximate solution very quickly
it's not solving exactly the problem
that you want to solve but hopefully
it's solving something that's close
enough and another thing that you might
try for mixed effects because all of our
parameters are or most of our parameters
are assumed to be drawn from normal
distributions this works out to a pretty
complicated form of l2 regularization
and in particular what you get is this
sort of very big sparse block diagonal
penalty matrix and instead of doing that
because it's a huge pain in the neck you
might just approximate that matrix with
the identity matrix times some scalar
times some scalar so in other words
don't do all this complicated stuff just
use simple l2 regularization on
everything so I have some results for
that
[Music]
so I guess to compare these methods I
did it I implemented a few of these
methods on the movie lens data set and I
picked the big one which has 20 million
observations and there are some there
are ratings explicit ratings of use of
movies by users
and although rating is really ordinal I
decided to binarize it because all the
methods I am comparing are they all
support logistic regression they don't
all support ordinal logistic regression
but I will say again that if you want to
honor that your response variable
actually is ordinal then diamond does
support ordinal logistic regression I'm
just going to fit the very simple model
that learns bias terms for every user
and every item okay so to do this in
diamond you import the logistic
regression module and we input Sigma our
covariance matrix as a data frame and
let's see so we have an intercept for
every user and every movie and this
awkward structure is actually straight
from LMU for but for this example I just
input it by hand and we see that the
variances are pretty close to each other
0.9 and 1 and then we let's see we
instantiate our model and then we fit it
using this formula notation diamond is
an iterative method so we specify a
tolerance and maximum number of
iterations okay so how long did that
take so I am first of all to learn this
covariance data frame covariance matrix
I took a 5% sample of the movie lens
data and I fit it in our ulema 4 which
took an hour and then to fit estimate
the coefficients for the full data set
all 20 million observations
it took about 83 minutes to fit on my
garden-variety macbook pro in comparison
I used scikit-learn
to do simple global l2 regularization so
I just used cross-validation to pick one
regularization parameter which took 24
minutes
grid search might be a fair comparison
because here I have learned two
parameters which are used for
regularization whereas down here I've
only learned one but that's okay
and then scikit-learn is nice and fast
fitting it only takes a minute but you
wonder like okay but this is not right
as I said before
Dimond is solving the exact problem this
simple global l2 regularization is
solving a problem that might be close to
that problem kind of hard to say so
let's compare the predictions that the
two models output and lo and behold
they're um they're pretty similar and
scikit-learn is much faster but I think
this is somewhat of an artifact of the
movie lens data set in particular the
fact that our variances are so similar
means that approximating these two
numbers with one number is a pretty good
approximation so if you had if you had
more features or much different
variances I think this approximation
would not be as good if you tried to fit
all twenty million observations in our
Allen before I tried that took more than
six hours so I gave up so I know maybe
your patience is greater than mine but
when I say that elma for does not scale
well with a number of observations this
is what I mean there's also an active
area of research into using the method
of moments to estimate these kind of
models and there are professors at NYU
and Stanford and maybe elsewhere that
are working on this and you can use
these techniques to fit kind of simple
models so models maybe with one group
and some features or no features but two
groups or but currently as of today
there are no moment based methods for
fitting multiple groups with features
but to give you some idea of the
performance
let's see I fit ours I fit this model on
the 20 million movie lens data and it
took four minutes so I'm not sure
exactly what my patience is but it's
less than six hours and but four minutes
is adequate that's fast enough for me I
also tried fitting this model this is
the same model that's learning user and
item biases using Edward Edward has a
black box variational inference
functionality which I will admit I do
not understand very well or really at
all and this fit in under five minutes
so I think very very small difference is
very exciting and I think there are some
talks at this conference about fitting
Bayesian models and maybe something that
will cover variational inference so if
your I will be at those maybe I will see
you there okay so I ran through a bunch
of examples and I think in none of them
did diamond-like outperform the
comparison so you might be wondering
like why should I use it so let me give
you some qualitative reasons why you
might consider using it
compared to Markov chain Monte Carlo
sampling or ellamy for it does scale
well with the number of observations so
I was able to fit you know fit a simple
model to 20 million observations in a
reasonable amount of time it does solve
the exact problem so compared to
variational difference or moment based
methods it's really solving the the it's
solving the exact problem not an
approximation of the problem
and this could be more or less important
depending on the problem and how strict
you are it scales okay with the number
of features compared to a simple global
LT regularization and as I mentioned
before it supports ordinal logistic
regression so if you want to honor your
response variable and it's ordinal
nature diamond supports this
so I hope I have convinced you that mix
effects models are useful for
recommender systems and other
applications of data science there are
some computational challenges and they
can be hard to fit to large data sets
but there are some good approaches for
doing so which include Diamond the
package that we wrote the moment based
approaches and variational inference and
also you don't have to choose you can
use moment you can use mixed effects
models in conjunction with whatever
models are your favorites or that you're
already using that's all
[Applause]
questions comments yes I do I didn't
include in this presentation but on cago
right now there's a competition for
music recommendation for a service
called kkbox so I've been doing some
experiments using like XG boost to learn
like feature interactions about users
and items and then using mixed effects
models to learn the user and item biases
I think that the parametric
specification of those bias terms is a
better way to learn them than the kind
of like one hot encoding you might learn
in next you know in a next reboost kind
of model yes
I'd be happy to do that so what this
what this represents is how different
the user the users and the items are
from each other so I can give you so in
the title data set that I was just
talking about I guess what this
represents is so the the variance term
for users or for items just represents
how what the spread is between them so
if all of the if all of the movies are
have the same popularity then the
variance will be very small close to
zero but but if the users you know have
like wildly different levels of
pickiness like some people just always
always hate everything and some people
always love everything that will be a
very large variance so for that for the
kkbox data set the variances are like an
order of magnitude different for users
and for for in that example it's in that
dataset songs yes
let's see that's a good question
[Music]
if you I would say that if you're
interested in doing inference on models
like this that the way to do it is
through a fully Bayesian perspective and
probably doing like MCMC sampling if you
just want to find like the maximum
a-posteriori estimates variational
reference actually certainly diamonds
will give you that diamond does not give
you the standard errors but I think that
that fully Bayes fully Bayesian way of
fitting is the way is advisable if
you're interested in doing inference yes
absolutely
you can have you can have all kinds of
varying slopes and intercepts as complex
as you as you like yeah for this example
I just let the slope vary because sorry
I just let the intercept vary because I
had this intuition about you know
different silhouettes need to be have
different lengths maybe there's some
reason that the way that height affects
the ideal length of jeans also varies by
silhouette but I didn't have much
intuition about that but you could
certainly fit a model like that which
would give you lines with varying slopes
as well as different different
intercepts and Dimond certainly supports
that you
yes yeah so I would say that's a nice
advantage of you know using something
that's built on linear models because
what you'll get if you haven't worked if
you have more features here if you have
more features that you're more if you're
learning a bunch of slopes for each
silhouette let's say what you'll get is
a vector of coefficients for every
silhouette and then you can look at
those and visualize them and make some
nice make some nice plots of them so I
mean it does give you like this is still
linear models you do get coefficients on
features that you that you create so I
would say in that sense yeah what you
get is still pretty interruptible I
would also like to mention that since
they're built on linear models it's easy
to serialize them and put them in
production because for making
predictions you're just doing a dot
product of a matrix of coefficients and
some vector so it's easy to
productionize models like this yes
great question I'm really glad you asked
that question so what happens in that
case yeah yes so the question is what if
you have like just a user who has only
rated one thing does this throw off
throw it off so you could fit hmm
so yeah what happens if you don't use
any regularization and you just fit a
straight linear model which you will get
is you'll be able to predict that you
that users one rating perfectly because
you can over fit it exactly so what
makes to fix models do is for small
groups in this case a user who only has
one rating they're the regularization
will pull them so that their prediction
is more like the average prediction for
all users or in this case in a model
like in a model like this because our
user bias terms are drawn from this
normal normal distribution centered at
zero the estimate for that user will be
pulled toward zero and you know as the
optimizer trades off the penalty with
the loss function there's not much gain
to be had it doesn't decrease it doesn't
decrease the loss very much for that
user to have a large value but it does
increase the penalty a lot so mixed
effects models learn to kind of trade
off starting from the global average and
then with more observations letting
users or items behave in their own way
so and I think this reflects kind of the
intuition that many of us have that if
you know nothing about a user or an item
it should behave like the average and
then as we observe it more and more will
allow it to behave in its own special
way
last chance for questions yes
I didn't that's a good good question so
question is about you know performance
with more complex models in terms of a
number of observations I'm not I'm not
sure certainly there's some advantage to
having like this you know sort of rigid
parametric model form but I did not
measure that
right thanks again everyone
[Applause]